but i was on dancing with the stars in
2009 how's that for you dude i
i don't want to talk bad about it
because
they were they were wonderful people
yeah i know
my experience was
terrible
my my experience was pretty terrible too
because
i didn't realize how much work actually
you had to put in i mean
dancing and practicing yeah they like
for me when i did it though i don't know
about you but for me when i did it
they already the dances were already a
minute and a half
and they shortened the time
for dances as the seasons progressed i
think i i feel like i only had a mint to
do and then on mondays we would then we
would have to do two minute dances or
and two of them
it wasn't that yeah and then and then i
took i i stole karina smirnoff my
partner from the other guy on the show
maxim
oh you you hung up with her yeah yeah we
i basically stole her like from him and
then they broke off their engagement and
then and then karina and i just didn't
click and then half like we were about
to win
and then she got mad at me because i
basically didn't want to be i didn't
want to be like with her with her and
was like
stomping my feet on purpose during live
performances
with those heels
like she was just and she would like
knee me in the balls real quick like you
know like
she was in the show yeah because she
just didn't want to be on it anymore
with me and she was mad and
she's rushing and then i ended up dating
the russian later and oh my god like
russian women they're so beautiful but
man holy they will they will slice your
throat open have you ever uh revealed
that or is that an exclusive for them no
that's that that i got a lot of only
exclusives just for you guys yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]